unfortunately you know what regardless
of what generation you are
yeah you know debt is a way of life here
in america that is no friend of ours i
always say that debt is your money going
backwards it's the worst four-letter
word on the planet depending on the debt
that you have you can throw throw some
four-letter words dave we'll bleep it
out oh just kidding don't do it but
that's the worst you know thing to have
especially when you want to succeed in
life yeah so basically here's the debt
difference between
millennials and gen z let's see what we
got going on so according to the new
state of credit 2021
report from experian one of three major
credit reporting bureaus you got
experian you got uh equifax and a trans
is that what it is trans union
um
here's some here's some uh numbers that
they've given us okay
so they're basically saying take a look
at these numbers get a load of these so
they start with average credit card debt
average credit card debt gen z which are
basically they don't start it until
you're age 18. even though mr perfect
gen z 18 to 24 the average credit card
debt 2 300 bucks okay they're in college
they just got out of college 20 30 bucks
on the other hand millennials oh boy age
25 to 40 me being the oldest millennial
40 you being the youngest 40 i'm sorry
that's right the youngest millennial no
the oldest one you're the oldest on the
other correct
millennials on the other hand 4 500
bucks
okay 45 that's average credit card now
put in perspective the u.s average when
you you know you know yeah silent
generation the old school traditionalist
you got the baby boomers you got gen
xers
uh average credit card debt
closer to 5 500 bucks average okay okay
so the takeaway is gen z
trends are not on your side
the older you get the more you run up
credit card debt so take notice and
don't go down that path if you're
averaging 2 300 bucks millennials are 4
500 and then as you get into the all
across the board us average closer to 5
500 6 grand almost
save that money don't put it on the
credit card okay average mortgage debt
right now think about it before i get
into these numbers gen z if you're 18 to
24 let's say 18 to 25 you're not exactly
buying houses yet i would suspect
but some people are
gen z average mortgage debt 192 000 for
gen z 192 whereas millennials average
mortgage debt 255 000 okay about a
quarter million dollars whereas you have
the u.s average 229 000 so millennials
are above the u.s average millennials
for whatever reason
they want to buy houses we always hear
reports saying millennials are
struggling to buy houses yeah i don't
know after since the pandemic there's
people been on a buying spree to buy
houses i can tell you why right now tell
me millennial i mean it's that pressure
again from your parents that came from
that hey buy a house we bought property
so i mean i'm i'm being told right now
like hey when i mean get buy buy
property buy yeah isn't this thing about
the crash
give me a second good point david it's
definitely that hey i would like to know
from our people in the comments section
are people pressuring you to buy real
estate to buy a house to buy a mortgage
members yeah yeah
well let's transition to that we'll talk
about that transition the average
non-mortgage debt so this is all your
debt just not including the house gen z
12 500. okay we love debt in america
baby so even our youngsters are starting
off just out of high school just out of
college 12 500.
um
millennials 28 000 okay so you're you're
more than double whereas the u.s average
is closer to 25 000. so basically
millennials are taking on
debt to your point
yeah i believe that millennials have
sort of been indoctrinated to get the
house the car the student loans the
college all that they've indoctrinated
that lifestyle by their boomer parents
yeah well you know you got to go to a
good school you know you gotta get a car
you gotta you gotta um save up for a
down payment on a mortgage you gotta you
gotta buy a house you gotta do that
whereas gen z
they've kind of seen the the writing on
the wall right they've seen it and
they're like
i don't know if i need to go to college
i've seen this student yeah like you
said yeah the gary's really ugly right i
don't know if i need a car i can just
uber yeah right i don't know if i need
to get a mortgage i can just rent the
place with my homies and get a roommate
so gen z i think
for my gen z friends out there
learn you know if they say if you don't
learn from history you're destined to
repeat it yeah look at millennials
drowning in debt
drowning in debt mortgage debt credit
card debt student loans consumer debt
gen z if you're paying attention because
not everyone does most people are most
people we all know that that's why the
average is the average gen z the smart
ones are gonna take a look and say
i don't know i don't know if you need to
go to college i can make a lot of money
online i don't know if i need a car i
can uber i don't know if i need to buy a
house just gonna get a roommate
times have changed let me change with
the times yeah exactly you know like we
talked about a couple episodes episodes
ago
uh
these new dogs can't be doing old tricks
and hopefully gen z is recognizing that
and even it's i mean who are the parents
of gen z burned millennials like older
millennials that have been through that
gen xers or or exactly gen x's but also
i mean they're millennial parents and
then
they were teaching like hey dude i i got
into that don't maybe
so yeah things to consider anyway so
that is the difference between
millennials and gen z when it comes to
debt now let's
since we're on the topic of debt that
you know as we say
uh worst four-letter word nobody likes
that d-e-b-t that's the worst
four-letter word in the world now
there's people are gonna be out there
like what do you mean
there's good debt bro there's good debt
bro i get it if you can get a mortgage
rate that's
you know very low take a business loan
that's very low i get it but inherently
debt is bad debt is your money going
backwards now obviously if you can get
cheap rates
and invest or buy something that
appreciates cool good luck but overall
debt
is
negative okay let's just establish that
yeah okay now not you know there's gonna
be people out there that say i agree
with you saz
that's the worst get out of debt be
debt-free which i am completely
debt-free i owe nobody nothing it's a
great feeling there's gonna be people on
the other side of coin a lot of real
estate type people they're gonna say
well look you need to kind of take on
some debt if you're gonna buy some
property invest play the appreciation
game do all that i get it there's both
sides of the
all we talk coin money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken
you